electricity is one of our most faithful  servants it gives us light it cooks and  refrigerates our food  these represent few of the innumerable  applications of electricity electricity  at work but what is electricity what is  electricity what what what is  electricity  one two three song about electricity  because it powers our lives makes it  possible for us surprised because the  powers online thanks impossible for us  surprise the four five six both the  potential difference makes electrons go  around if the circuit is completely  sound  power  USIC in factories  because we  ah  finnstrom his love  so what is electricity  one two or three song about electricity  because the powers our lives makes it  possible for us to bribe lose the pounds  online thanks impossible for us the  prize  five six votes uh potential difference  makes electrons go around if the circuit  is completely sound  six  in factories  I said what is electricity  a gun  can you  No  Oh  where  our juicer